the moment that I realized getting my
parents approval was worthless was
because I kind of like your parents
where they're like you have to give like
a Chinese girl whatever I was like okay
let's say I get with a non-asian chick
and we uh have the best marriage ever or
I get with the Asian chick and we're
fighting every day
which one would you rather have me have
and I remember my dad going that's
impossible he wrote the Asian chick
there's just so many things like in line
just as impossible were your parents
together still at this point no
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boy today we have geoquan with
us
to go
uh a lot of people are upset because we
kind of didn't reach a good I guess
lesson or a good point or a good answer
because we messed around too much
basically
on just kidding news no do it again one
of those where like the topic was good
are we [__] up yeah and I think like
people were waiting they were waiting
for the real answer which we all have we
just think it's you know not as funny so
we just kept trying to be funny and
admittedly we even were like hey we
should do that again sometime and just
really like be real because there's a
lot of actuality in it that people don't
have and let's let's give a shot okay
why do Asians feel like it's more
difficult to date white women all right
all right if you grew up in a pretty
Asian area and you've dated Asian men
and you've observed a lot and you've
dated Asian men and it's non-asian
people that also perpetuate them wait is
it specifically white girls or is it
just non-asian girls because I've heard
about so especially in the early 2000s
right like I've heard
people say like non-asian girls don't
like us I've heard that a lot and then
um from guys that don't date in general
from guys that don't even have Asian
girlfriends and not saying that that's
like a lesser or more I'm just saying
like they don't even date within the
culture but they already have it in
their heads that outside of Asians they
won't they won't get any girlfriends or
whatever and it's usually from guys that
grew up in Asian neighborhoods that
don't have access and exposure to other
cultures I like their sheltered kind of
they're so sheltered that they make up
these things in their head and it might
be true for other reasons not because of
race but because maybe you're just not
you're awkward as [__] bro
desirable to women period yeah you know
it's not because you're an Asian male
because what if you're an Asian male
that's athletic and charismatic and all
these things
women in general like those traits it's
not the race that they date it's the
individual that they date and desire so
then in my head I just couldn't wrap my
head around this internal racism but it
is true for a lot of people they really
feel this way yeah and so like it is a
joke because of how Preposterous I think
that statement is but it's true for so
many [__] people what was the
question again it's like why why do
Asian why do Asian guys feel like it's
more difficult to date white women oh I
see I think growing up going back to
what Joe was saying like it was it was
something you would hear all the time
that's okay that's that's where I'm at
with it I think I think that's a big
part of it I think you hear it before
you say it about yourself yeah which is
a little bit fun and then that becomes
your truth that becomes what because
people everyone says it that's true and
especially at a certain impressionable
age where
um you just hear it all the time that's
what you think is true but like for me
growing up
um
I didn't really grow up with like that
many Asian kids you know and like Asian
males at least yeah but the Asian males
would find themselves like
typically more attracted to Asian women
you know I don't know if it's because
they feel like they had to or that's
just like what their preference was so I
think that could be maybe it's easier to
reach a common ground faster yeah
so it's easier to communicate the
certain values because even me as long
as I've been with my wife like there's
certain things that I couldn't really
communicate culturally like the
differences and like articulate it
properly because I didn't really like
Know Myself yeah so like there are
challenges when you are like talking or
dating in certain ways but I think a lot
of it is like self-inflicted I think it
really is like it's a narrative and then
if you want to take it a step further to
like maybe like Media or movies or
things that we we consume so much of
what I consumed or so much of what I
thought of the world was consumed
through TV and media and I thought
that's what the truth was like oh white
people date white people black people
date black people yeah there was very
very few representation Concepts like in
media about like Asian dudes that were
like bagging the White Chicks especially
rarely saw except for Bruce Lee okay the
one anomaly but but he was running on a
pedestal also at the same with the guy
he was the one yeah exactly so there is
no other if there was like if he was
buried and there's like 30 other Asian
dudes that I'm like okay cool like
that's something you have to dig up to
find the guy that did it but he's not
he's the one and it's weird that he was
bagging him in real life but not in his
films yeah yeah yeah so then they didn't
even trust that as a representative
remember Romeo Must Die absolutely that
was the one that I was like yeah
and they're like supposed to be romantic
interests but they barely [__] hugged
yeah they don't even make eye contact
with each other yeah it was like a whole
[__] thing so like growing up as a
kid sometimes you see that and then at
an impressionable age like oh that's
just what the world is like that's just
the truth so I could only talk about my
own experience and I think my own
experience is also uh it's both romantic
and in Social and making friends because
I feel like when you're born
kids don't see color at all yeah they're
just friends with everyone right so um
where I grew up was pretty diverse and
my first girlfriend was white but it
wasn't even like she was white it was
just
she's just a girl she's a girl yeah I
was in second grade she gave me a kiss
on the cheek my whole body turned red
and I didn't know I thought I had a
fever I'd never felt feelings like that
in my entire life and we had a very it
was just a very like diverse group then
I go into
um Junior High and you have friends that
are like oh you got skaters you gotta
build a break or whatever and then it
was like still a very diverse group so I
never had this concept of certain races
only date certain races ever right until
I moved here
when I moved here one thing that I saw
was even the in the high school the
dudes don't even make friends with other
dudes and other races so I think that
it's it's actually like what I think is
first you have to know how to interact
with people
and then after you learn how to interact
with people in general you learn how to
interact with people's cultures because
cultures tend to they tend to have their
own way of communicating and then you
have to know how to interact with
cultures of the opposite sex so that you
can flirt the right way yeah versus
people might just right away like like
for example if you've been in like a
very like
super Korean K-Town type group the way
you flirt with those chicks is going to
be way different than a white girl
volleyball team you know what I mean
it's just you have to I think and I
think the reason why there's that saying
like oh we can't get white chicks or
other chicks or whatever is because it
might be really true to them because
they don't have the tool set to even
make a white friend a white platonic
male friend or a black friend they might
go oh I want to be friends with this guy
but I don't even know how to like build
rapport because maybe they grew up in a
really super sheltered area or maybe
they were the minority in the area so
the five Asian kids stuck together but
um so I think I was fortunate enough to
have had such a diverse upbringing that
like out of Indian friends didn't see it
that way I didn't see it that way at all
but when I moved here that's when I
started hearing stuff like that right
right and I was like wait what what do
you mean like they'll even be like uh
but like I hear like homies
and I'm like I
seen a Korean homie knock the [__] out
of a black guy I'm like we're all human
beings you know and and I wrestled so
we're wrestling all Multicultural people
I've seen [__] every single color
race get pinned we're all human beings
but people have these not just the White
Chicks but like
every single different race and
stereotype they're somehow built into
their mind because they haven't been
able to kind of like find a way to
interface first and after you know how
to interface then you can flirt because
flirt is like the second level of
communication I think that's the best
answer right there you know contrary to
what I like to say about bart that was
actually really good I think I think you
nailed it for sure because there is like
you when you go hang out with certain
groups of people the cultural aspect
like how they make jokes how they
interact how they get along is so
important and I think for some people
they're just naturally good at it or
they can naturally pick up those
patterns and some people are just like
I'm not gonna even try yeah you know
yeah I also think it was like maybe more
exacerbated by our time right like um
like when we go through high school and
stuff like that you didn't really get
social media so you weren't really
sharing culture as quickly and learning
about people yeah that's true that's
true you learned it from like your high
school gossip groups and what you were
comfortable with or what you stuck to
and maybe some of your friends were like
your friends because you went to either
basketball camp or like Chinese school
together and so like you started
sticking kind of in your like clicks
that made you feel really comfortable I
went to Sunny Hill so it was like [__]
tons of Asians so like this the the
separation of like there's this there's
like 50 something percent Asians at my
school and then like 40 that were like
white and then 20 anything else you know
what I'm saying so at that time it was a
it was very clear there was like like a
racial
separation or or just thing going on
because people didn't really like kick
it yeah not really or if you did kick it
you know what I mean or or if one Asian
dude was like dating a white girl like
it was
I was like wow it was noticeable you
know what I'm saying
okay exactly you know what I'm saying so
whereas like in today's world it's like
like now you it's I feel like it's so
much so much more like clear that like
uh you know the stereotypical uh white
chick who's like super into like anime
you know what I'm saying like weave
girls and stuff yeah so like for some
reason today I don't think of that as as
much like I don't think like all Asian
guys can't get white girls today at all
yeah you know what I mean remember we
were going up and and I remember a time
and I'm talking like in my 20s now that
I'm watching commercials of interracial
relationships and I'm like holy [__]
this is groundbreaking and now it's so
common yeah that's what people don't
really like give
um attention to is how segregated we've
been in America like there's this facade
of diversity and whatever but it's
actually very recent we're like well
they call it a Melting Pot right yeah
there's no melting happening in
interracial marriage was actually legal
in 1960 or 70. that's not that's [__]
recent segregation
desegregated in the 60s and then so like
even the cultural like kind of taboos of
like
everyone will ask in Asian communities
if you're dating outside the race
they'll ask the first thing is oh does
their family accept you why is that a
thing like the first thing in their
heads is like oh they're a white family
or whatever are they gonna be okay with
that yeah because everybody knows that
like they must have had an experience or
something where they fear that kind of
racism or something yeah yeah it's
recent enough it's recent enough yeah or
it's taught to us to know that like yeah
and then so when I did ask guys that
have these mentalities or whatever about
like oh uh non-asian girls don't aren't
into us or whatever I'm like what
happened and they'll be like oh yeah I
was at this part I was just trying to
talk to this girl and she's like ooh
Asians or like they'll get comments like
that like seriously rejection because
they're Asian or whatever right so I'm
like oh I get that but then
why would you want that trash anyway
like
a person that thinks that way like does
that that person represent all of white
or all of whatever culture you have one
idiot that rejected you but that doesn't
reflect the ideas and thoughts of
everybody in that race if you grew up
listening to like what Nick was saying
that that is that is what's constantly
repeated and passed down to you so it's
like a confirmation bias exactly where
it's like C you know like it is true
like I don't want it to be true but I
just experienced it so therefore it must
be true and now it just it's like
especially at that age right it's like
out here for my dad sometimes like my
dad would say stuff like my mom's like
Oh white people that's just so strong
why the fuzz Johnny allergic to
everything then
look at all that sunburn yeah I will I
will say that um granted like when I was
really young my mom would always I would
joke around with her and this is [__]
up now it didn't age well but I would
joke around with her back then because I
knew that she would get mad at me if I
like was dating like a black girl right
and so I'd be like oh yeah I just
started dating a black girl because I
knew she would just be like what she
wouldn't like explicitly be like that's
wrong I think I just know it would
trigger something for her you know it
should be surprised or something and so
there's this like subconscious
development and I remember because I
remember when I finally started dating
somebody uh in college that was exactly
like me in terms of uh Vietnamese
culture but Chinese blood I remember
thinking like oh my God like my parents
would be so proud except she's a [__]
it didn't work out but you know what I'm
saying like there was this weird
subconscious feeling that if I like were
to bring this type of girl home it would
be accepted and and also like praise and
like I would make my parents proud and
you know I never really got a chance to
fully dissect that but there's something
like you said like when there's like a
um a cultural like uh Common Ground yeah
the Rapport aspect yeah right you just
feel like that's uh that's gonna be
convenient or right or or it works with
your family and there's all these things
that are like prose and complimentary
that you're like that's the right thing
to do so then you start also developing
this other subconscious thing where
you're like dating outside of your race
maybe it's like a farther grasp you know
what I mean it's not it's either less
attainable and or just not realistic I
don't know there are just so many random
things that started happening and it
wasn't until I started dating outside of
my race and I was like oh [__] it's
regular [__] you know what I mean it's
just another person yeah you just gotta
you build rapport individually with
everyone there's no like oh you have to
you know I remember like because I was
like a scoundrel as a kid like this the
Scoundrels they all scallywag yeah the
Scoundrels they all hang out with each
other you know and then you would like
hang out with Like A Cholo or whatever
or to hang out with like a white skater
kid that like gets in trouble and is
getting kicked out of skate parks all
the time and there's just like this the
the Rapport language is down yeah who's
down right and then I'm like oh [__]
like this Mexican dude doesn't like the
Mexican nerd as much as I don't like
this [__] Asian ass [__] geek and
I think that's that's really what what
is the biggest truth here is that
regardless of race right I think class
brings people together way far yeah
because I connect way more with people
that grew up similar to me in the same
class more than rich Asian kids yeah
yeah like the kids that grew up in San
Marino like we look culturally the same
maybe we celebrate the same holidays or
whatever but then
it's really hard to have a close
friendship and relationship and we bump
heads a lot because of what we value as
like oh this is how friendship should be
this is how loyalty should be like we
have a different set of I guess existing
in rules and [__] right yeah we're like
I get it maybe in in their circles like
they probably have a whole different set
of what's okay because all of my like
rich Asian friends that were like dating
each other violating all the codes that
we thought was wrong it was fine with
them you know they're [__] each other
all day long they would like cheat like
financially against each other all day
long but they were still friends and
then I'm like that's the weirdest thing
to me because those would be deal
breakers in my culture like in my group
and like and I know I can talk to a
Mexican guy or any white guy or whatever
and we would agree on those set of rules
and I think that's the biggest [__] is
people focus so much on Race not knowing
like culture in America with class is
what ties us way tighter 100 yeah
because our worlds are the same I like
we buy the same [__] we we share the
same type of like we'll probably go to
the same experiences in the same
restaurants right like we're all going
to [__] like Outback Steakhouse and
they're all going somewhere else yeah so
it's completely different
I remember trying to like uh the moment
that I realized getting my parents
approval was worthless was because I
kind of like your parents where they're
like you have to give like a Chinese
girl whatever I was like okay let's say
I get with a non-asian chick
and we uh have the best marriage ever or
I get with the Asian chick and we're
fighting every day
which one would you rather have me have
and I remember my dad going that's
impossible you throw the Asian chick
there's just so many things like in line
it just is impossible I'm like I have a
ton of Asian friends that fight with all
the [__] together still at this point
no
exactly right like parents that's
impossible
they're walking like [__]
self-contradicting things but they don't
they can't put themselves yeah but you
know and I was like I'm not gonna prove
to you anything anymore it's like people
judge the KKK guys that are like stick
with your own kind and all that [__]
right yeah but then when minorities do
it within themselves no one's judging
that [__] yeah and then to me like if I
date a non-japanese that's already
dating outside of the race for me yeah
because it's so different like even
within Asians yeah we might have
Confucianism and Buddhism and whatever
the ties together
I was like so confusion but like to me
that's the same thing is like [__] how
close is a Russian person and a Spanish
person they're both European and they
both can look white but how their
cultures are so different yeah so I'm
like
I don't know like how true this is when
it comes to like oh sticking with your
own kind or you're not I don't know it's
so weird because America in general
they're [__] racist you know what I
mean so like whoa hey dude we'll talk
about country like that man
but you know what I mean like that's
that's the stereotype that so many other
countries have uh when they look at
America we're obsessed with race for
sure yeah we're just obsessed with this
so even the fact that like you know
having a discussion about this type of
topic you know and
having race constantly be something that
we're just like thinking about talking
about yeah it enters that space and it
makes us not like a kid anymore where we
don't see like colors you know or we
just you know like everybody's our
friend because now we're everybody
society's talking about race and the
separation of different things so you're
constantly thinking about it as if it
really plays a part you know what I mean
versus just being like if nobody just
talked about it then and everybody just
did it like what examples would we have
like what questions would be popped up
you know yeah all of my friends in the
UK they say like dude I don't know
what's up with Asian guys in the States
but y'all are so race obsessed and then
they're like we grew up in such a
diverse environment where everyone just
like like Bart's example of elementary
school kids just dating multiculturally
yeah for them I and I and this is why I
go back to the whole point like if
you're an Asian kid that grew up with
only Asians you don't have exposure to
other cultures and anything so then you
make up in your own mind you have an
imagination of how other cultures might
view you yeah
experiences with other cultures yeah I
saw like how different it was because uh
we would go to like the college shows
and then like the Chinese whatever
Student Association or whatever they
actually formed because they felt like a
small group on the campus so they wanted
to get back with their Roots versus the
high school like cereals high school
when I first went there
like the Filipino Club had like white
people Indian people whatever it was
just their friends and their friends
that want there's it's so diverse people
wanted to learn about their friend's
[__] so I was like oh [__] this is so
[__] crazy that in one group when
people are so it's so diverse that
that's already out of the question
there's no like oh I want to get a white
girl like there's no one on a pedestal
everyone just understands people are
people people just want a good
girlfriend or a good boyfriend and that
type of
um Dynamic was like that's why they they
could date it everyone because they're
like I just want to get to know who you
are at Nick not Nick the singer porn or
whatever you know but then in the other
group if you haven't had that kind of
Rapport if you you put all these other
races oh this person has better immunity
than me
yeah just such a weird way of thinking
but I also understand yeah how they got
there yeah and so I guess my advice
would be like put yourself in more
interests because generally the more
interest you go in like even with death
the ACT is one of the most Multicultural
like
um activities you could do
put yourself in there and you get you
need to see like hella people that
sometimes I see [__] people that
don't even have like swagless and my
husband can't dance for [__] they come
out of [__] all crazy and [__] and
I'm like that's like the best place to
put yourself in where you you're just
combined by interest and through the
interest you meet a whole like plethora
of different types of people and you
learn how to build rapport and you just
realize everyone's just human beings and
you have to establish common ground with
no matter who you meet because that's
always going to be more that's the key I
think because a lot of people want to
put a large responsibility on media and
they'll go oh I didn't see that in this
movie or when you look at the 90s movies
and they depict so many Asian people as
just the dorks and they're like oh look
what that did to us yet movies and media
are responding to consumerism so they're
gonna sell you what they believe you'll
buy movies don't get the credit now for
being Progressive because they're
responding to what we are doing yeah so
it's your responsibility to push against
whatever you you believe is wrong and do
what you feel is right and then the
movies will start making what you're
doing in real life because they go oh
that's true that's who people want to
see they want to see more ethnic people
they're not doing it to as a favor
it makes money it makes money it's
always money-based that's also happening
William Hung came out and all the Asians
are so [__] ashamed where's the heart
throw up Asians I'm like man I know
plenty of hard drive Asians in real life
I like this [__] that's this
guy's different guys I always you know
because we were right in that era too
where like we would there was really no
opportunities for Asians in
entertainment and all that and there
were a lot of people going like dude it
sucks how they make they like
de-masculine like they feminize men and
all that stuff especially Asian guys
they're just like the lacking stock of
the whatever we totally did that and
then they did that and I get it but then
I always thought in real life sensible
women will want they won't they'll just
laugh at the jokes but they'll be
attracted to a man they'll be attracted
to good qualities and the guy so I was
like if I run into attractive girl
regardless of what race we could get
together and we'll go to the movies and
watch William hunger whatever the [__]
and laugh at it together but then
so so I also would talk to these guys
that believe these things about like oh
you know the man is keeping us down they
don't like Asians [__] trying to come
up or whatever
um and I told them dude it's not really
the white guy's job to Wing man for us
like yeah it's not so you're telling all
these Hollywood producers to make a risk
and make an Asian heartthrob and then
make a movie about an Asian dude [__]
all the women in the world like a Rico
Suave it's kind of tired and I'm like
that is cool but then at the end of the
day like you have to put in work like
all like all of you guys if you want to
go out there and be a romantic human
being dress better look better get fit
look clean and they're both sidarsos
yeah dude Chino Suave dude that's true
understand how to flirt understand how
to be social like what do you what are
you wishing is that like some hot girl
goes oh my God I wish I [__] knew
you're you're you've been there all my
life I just [__] didn't see you
because you were Asian you took your
glasses let me just suck your dick you
know
what I mean everyone should be trying to
strive to do better if you really want
that's what I think makes a change you
need to work on yourself and work work
on getting rejected a thousand times
before you find the person that will
accept you oh [__] you know like I mean
like it's hard though but that's the
thing it's hard for a lot of men
especially if you're unattractive I
think that's really what changes media
like we have it in our minds a lot that
like oh we need to see these guys on
screen no you just need to see them in
real life yeah yeah and the more you see
in real life the more those people have
those life experiences and those writers
and those people and those producers can
say I know a guy like this if they don't
know a guy like that and they only know
nerds that's all they're gonna write in
that's true but I do have to say on the
flip side though there is some truth to
the media stuff because ever since K-pop
your guys's [__] bad stuff there's
like a image now of what this is there's
exposure of like Asian content right
Asian like guys in the Romantic world
with K dramas coming out and like this
is what it's like being in a
relationship with an Asian man now they
can imagine the relationship of this
example yeah I know they see it and then
they might desire that
but do you want the one that desires
that because they're usually like really
overweight blue-haired white girls that
are weebs
the character on screen that's like an
Asian nerd and like not the heartthrob
and he's the hateable character
and a lot of Asian people get mad like
oh how dare you put something like that
it's like no we all know a [__] guy
like that and we all bullied him too
it's like that's a real guy like as much
as we hate to admit it that is a real
Asian person it's the guys that look
like that that are mad a lot of a lot of
generational Asian culture cultivated
that person to exist that way because
that was the value of prioritizing
success over image over like popularity
it's like no be smart be this because
who gives a [__] if you're not cool you
have no social skills that happened a
lot and there's a lot of Asian victims
of that kind of parenting you're right
you know what I mean I mean it produced
Jack Ma
and he's killing it now dude I will say
to all the followers out there don't
listen to what I have to say in this
video because I'm the only one dating an
Asian chick but I applaud everybody else
here for your interracial relationships
you've never dated enough but all of the
sex you had yeah
I just said right now I'm trying to give
y'all props you [__] assets
Spanish sex Italians by the way
relationships with many Asian women like
for many years and and so the the he's
like but I have sex with Asians yeah
it's not about you jokes about Anthony
but yeah it is it also is like when when
people think of it as a novel thing when
they go hey I'm dating a white woman and
they think it's like a special it's
called um you know what it's called it's
it's called trophyism yeah that's not
that's not good like that bro it's
nothing like it's just a person okay
dude but that's what I don't also like
is like usually the guys that are saying
this it's like like going back to Bart's
like you're putting them on a totem pole
on the top of the totem pole and it's
like what about Asian girls then are
they at the bottom yeah that's messed up
oh white girls don't like us but Asian
girls do like oh you're you're running
your default settings come on man yeah
and then so it already is inherently
coming from a space where women are just
like this it's not even a human it's a
it's a prize yeah and then that and
where white women are at the top and I
don't [__] like do this activity like
where are all the racial girls let's
just do it one time for the video just
so we get it out the way which one
complains the most like that one yeah or
which one but it goes back to what Joe
said just get girls to like you first
and then worry about the race stuff
later just yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
friends first just get free just be cool
yeah hey you gotta like you first too
right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we all hate
ourselves that's why he's all out of [__]
I hope we did it justice this time guys
foreign